broken is too strong a word not it's
it's certainly true that when the public
is gets really fed up really really fed
up with politicians they get turned out
you know you can talk all you like about
oh look i have i have a whole shelf of
books written in 2005-2006 about how how
the republicans had a lock on power and
it didn't matter they had so many
advantages and then comes the 2006
election and they get they get tossed
out so the political system is not
broken but it certainly is distorted and
you have enormous monetary influence of
of the lobbyists you have a lot of very
often very often people are not getting
their views reflected most conspicuously
right now everybody not everybody but a
heavy majority wants out of iraq and
somehow is not happening but also you
can see we have something like should
hedge fund managers pay taxes like you
and me and it's hard to think of any
argument that they shouldn't and yet
even the democrats in congress are
dragging their feet on closing that tax
loophole and if you don't think that has
a whole lot to do with campaign
contributions you know I've got a bridge
you might want to buy
well the first thing that just for the
scariest I the possibility of voting
fraud is just although it's not clear
that it's had a tremendous influence
that the possibility is enough to be
terrifying so I actually want a
technological revolution in vote
counting I think we need to use the
cutting edge technology which is hand
counted balanced with lots of people
watching the counting that's the way
that other countries have done it it's
you know the the amount of money
involved relative to the importance of
safeguarding democracy is trivial so we
should do that public funding for
elections campaign finance reform limits
on contributions you can do up to a
point but the fact of the matter is vast
amounts of money have a way of flowing
around any barriers you try to erect so
there's no real substitute for making
sure the candidates can be adequately
financed even if they don't have big
money behind